l'attentât bloch je vais demander à
franck antoine lui bien de bord vouloir
venir avec bien sûr alors on va et je
sais que vous adorez cette séquence chez
vous ça l'attentât bluff vous allez on
t'a bluff vous allez regarder dans la
tente ce qu'il y a vous allez décrire
aux téléspectateurs et à nos
chroniqueurs ça ne vous voyez vous les
trouvez vous dirais qu'ils bluffent qui
dit la vérité
moi je regarderai le dirait un truc et
vous vous dire après tous les trois mois
je vais vous dire ce que je vois dans la
tente
je vous le dis je vois bernard montiel
en train de prendre un coup de soleil
jusqu'aux oreilles franck qu'est ce que
vous voulez l'aider
allez-y tous les relais venez me dit oh
ouais c'est sûr produit je suis désolé
pour cet automne mais qu'est ce qu'on
voit là quelqu'un de physique je vous
rappellerai bhl est horrible sur
l'épouvantable mais c'est alors c'est
quoi qui jouit d'un cauchemar de se
voiler vous pros rible ce que tu vois à
adé que l'on peut prendre parti moi je
vois bernard montiel
mais non et c'est moi qui m'en parlent
[Applaudissements]
y'a pas bien d'un jeu on a on a bien
géré
[Applaudissements]
ça fait combien de temps que je leur
disais je vois pas pourquoi on quelqu'un
d'autre merci alors moi je vois mokobé
oui mokobé du 113 avec un lama la maj
voit ce que c'est mais mokobé du 113 je
ne sais pas qui c'est regardez regardez
s'ouvrit mokobé du 113 avec un lama mais
moi je vois une balle à omar alors
qu'est ce que vous voyez est rude
un hommage prévu ouais mounde ont
aiguisé en frères bogdanoff
voilà la raison
patrick bloche donc patrick chirac doit
vous prenez mon sexuelle doit penser
qu'à croyez qu à mokobé avec un lama
vous oui vous dites la vérité ça soit
dans vos yeux
c'est bon vous je crois à moundir je
crois pas trop vous prenez un renard et
caroline vous pas d'amundi rigole on va
regarder
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comme beckett avec qui nous sommes prêts
je regarderai ce qu'il ya dans cette
troisième cabinet shérif true son sujet
[Musique]
alors moi je vais vous dire ce que je
vois là je vois je vois gérard louvin
géant à louvain en train de boire 1
virgin mojito c'est possible a rien à
[ __ ]
est ce que vous voyez au alors bonsoir
c'est moi je vois michel drucker
complètement bourré
alors michel drucker bourré ou gérard
louvin cyril boissier pas croyant
mystery et bien sûr jean luc blanc s'en
sert il
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
en 2005 m
mon bateau et michel le parti
[Musique]